[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> So what's being done to resolve this massive
global issue?
Well, there are people trying to do their
best.
So a lot of small little, local charities
working in their communities
across Ethiopia or Cameroon or Ghana, and
these are generally women's
charities looking at empowerment of women.
Some of the larger charities are also working
on this.
And doing, again, what they can to have an
impact on communities.
And certainly bodies like UNICEF do have strategies,
have come up with
their ideas for solutions.
So it's not just been ignored.
This is the UNICEF-coordinated strategy to
abandon FGM in one
generation.
This is what the UN is saying it can do.
We can eliminate it.
We can abandon it in one generation.
But we're not.
This has been studied to death and what we
need to do now is get on and
do some implementation.
Eliminating FGM, this a statement that goes
across all of the UN
agencies.
All saying they're committed to eliminating
it.
What we need is a global push to commit to
these 3 million girls and
say enough is enough.
We've done the strategies, we've done the
talking, now we're going to
do something.
[MUSIC PLAYING]